[Music]
America is a diasporic country America
is a country you know we start with
native people in this land and then
people were brought here sometimes
involuntarily
sometimes voluntarily but in diaspora
from other parts of the globe so of
course there is the African Diaspora
largely brought here involuntary there
are people who come in diasporas from
Europe under different sets of
circumstances from Asia and different
sets of circumstances in continuing
waves throughout American history
uniquely American so I think that what
is amazing about this place is that it
has always received people who are
scattered from other places and then
made a mix that is uniquely its own I
think that in thinking about the
commonalities of of let's call them
immigrant or transplanted or the you
know the people who in various waves
come from elsewhere to make America
what's really important is while we can
sometimes see renewal and rebuilding I
think that those stories have very very
distinct particularity Xand it's
important for us not to flatten them you
know the slave experience the experience
of coming north in the great migration
is very different from coming here from
the Holocaust coming here from the
potato famine come in coming here from
other kinds of international either
crises or seeing the United States as
many have as a land of opportunity these
are very very distinct stories so I
don't mean to say that I don't think
they have any common denominator but I
think that they are more richly
understood in their particularity well I
think that what is important about
memory shaping our sense of legacy is
that who how memories are transmitted
how stories are told
has everything to do with what we
remember so you know that's why I think
that the work is really so important of
you know which books are taught which
projects are funded who gets the mic how
do we even have a chance to record and
then evaluate what a wide range of
American stories are so we can
understand who we really are I'm a part
of a school of thought in African
American Studies and and in sort of
revisionist histories that sort of say
okay well here's one timeline but
actually look at all of these other
stories that were not included on this
timeline you know the wonderful saying
you know the the lions are the victors
in history because the Lions write
history and when the Lions no longer
write history we'll have a different
history so if you think about how much
history has been told by people with
power and cultural resources you know
more male than not more white than not
more money than not more elite
institution affiliated than not how can
we understand that that's not all the
human beings right that's not all the
human beings so I've always been a
professor who goes back at one timeline
and says but look at this and this and
this and this all of these conversations
that were happening simultaneously and
by the way when you do that with culture
very often these poets for example who
were not placed on a narrow canonical
timeline together in their time we're
actually very much in interaction with
each other so I think that we actually
need to do the restorative work to
remember that human beings living in
proximity to each other are not always
unaware of each other in the way that
history sometimes has written it
throughout my career I have been working
to expand notions of where value
cultural value artistic value resides
when I was more engrossed in literary
study in particularly African American
literary study and women's studies
Gender Studies what we were always
trying to do was resent her
the cannon to say here are all of these
voices all of this brilliance that
either hasn't been taught or hasn't been
taught as any in anywhere other than on
the margins so if you think about works
that are now thought of as being quite
canonical like Zora Neale Hurston's
great novel Their Eyes Were Watching God
when I started out in graduate school
was not even in print it was something
that people handed you know tattered
copies from hand to hand and now it is
something that people are reading in
high schools in large part because of
the sort of feminist literary study in
African American literary study that
said this is neglected at excellence
this is excellence that should be read
by everyone and this is excellence that
is at the center of what is great in
American literature and that argument
was one that could be made using you
know basic tools of close reading but
also learning about how other traditions
in addition to the English literary
tradition and in addition to what sort
of elite institutions had put forth in
English departments how other traditions
had values that helped shape what made a
great work of art so but you know that's
sort of a long story to say that I
believe in a very interdisciplinary way
of understanding and shaping what
excellence is I think there is not only
one way that a work of art can achieve
greatness and I think that it's our
responsibility as smart funders just as
it is the responsibility of smart
educators to be able to understand works
of art and their achievement or failure
on their own terms and that's you know
kind of the complex way that we try to
think about what we fund
[Music]